- So Chuck,
I brought you here today.
- For lunch?
(laughing)
Clearly!
- You paying?
So, just to show the difference between
an average full moon,
and what people are
calling the super moon.
- Super moon!
- This being New York City,
pizza is the best sort of
circular object to reference.
- Yes, and it kind of looks like a moon,
a little bit.
- Yeah it's splotchy.
So, I went up to the front, and I said,
we're in Famous Ray's Pizza,
and I said,
I'd please like a 15 inch
pizza, which is here,
and a 16 inch pizza, which is here.
- [Chuck] And then they went,
who is this crazy dude?
- So, I said look,
I can do this,
we got this, okay.
So, point being,
the average size of the
full moon on the sky
is to a 15 inch pizza,
what the super moon is to a 16 inch pizza.
- So, what you see normally, okay,
- On average.
- Because the moon is
closer and farther...
- The moon is sometimes
closer, sometimes farther.
And that change in
difference, when it's closer,
it's a little bigger,
looks a little bigger,
when it's farther it
looks a little smaller.
It's an oval orbit around the Earth,
it's not a perfect circle.
If it was a perfect circle it would be
the same size all the time.
It can be at any phase at
any of these distances.
You can have a really big crescent,
or a big half moon.
- Nobody cares about that.
It's not a super half!
- Or super crescent, right.
You could say that, but no one is,
because we're somehow
fantasized about the full moon.
So, I'm just trying to show you
the difference between the two.
- Right.
- I want to take the 15 inch pizza.
- After we've measured it.
What are you doing?
Oh my God!
- Just, excuse me.
This is for science!
- Oh, God, okay.
- It is for science.
- Alright, this is for science.
Oh Lord Jesus, he is killing this pizza.
So, really, it's just a
little teeny bit bigger.
- A half inch all around.
Average full moon.
- Right.
- Super moon!
So, if that half inch is super to you,
- Right.
- On a pizza,
then, call the moon
what the hell you want,
but, in a pizza shop, nobody
here's calling this one super.
- Right.
- You don't come in and
say give me a super pizza,
and then you make it a half
inch bigger all around,
because a half inch and a
half inch makes an inch.
That's all I'm saying, Chuck.
- Oh, oh it's okay.
A super moon is a half inch
bigger than a regular moon.
- Why do you get to cut the pizza?
- Because I'm hungry!
I'll tell you what, no matter what,
this moon is delicious.
(grunting)
- Okay.
- Let's eat some moon
- Let's eat some moon, baby.
That don't sound good.
(laughing)